let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
okay well this should come as a shock
to no one really um in fact if you're a
thinking person it shouldn't in fact i
i predicted exactly this a week ago
and i'm barely a thinking person but
it's good to have some confirmation
so according to the attorney of the
officer involved in the jacob blake
shooting
the officer thought um you know going
back to that day
um the officer thought that jacob blake
was trying to kidnap a child
in fact the woman who called 9-1-1 that
would be blake's alleged rape victim
and ex-girlfriend was was screaming
according to the officer she was
screaming
he's got my kid he's got my keys and he
did he had the he had the
the his his alleged victims keys to her
car
and that's the car that he was trying to
get in it wasn't his car it was it was
the car didn't belong
he was trying to steal it apparently um
and she said that's what she was in
again she was indicating that he was
trying to steal the kids
and the car now as i said it was clear
from the beginning
that there was probably some kind of
domestic thing going on here involving
the kids
the officer also says that blake had a
knife had been fighting with the cops we
knew all of that
but now we also know according to the
officer anyway that and this is
consistent with the facts of the case
and everything we've seen with the
consistent with the evidence that blake
was trying to get into a car
not his car with a knife
evade a rest and drive away with three
kids
no way the officers could let him do
that so you know what
even even take take the knife out of it
resisting arrest everything
um just the idea of of letting a man
who is wanted for crimes wanted for
domestic abuse and sexual assault
uh to get into a car that is not his
and to evade a rest by driving away with
kids so he doesn't even we can presume
doesn't have custody of
there's just no way you can allow a
person to do that if you're a police
officer
you can't allow him to do that you have
to and any measure must be taken to
prevent that
and they tried non-lethal measures you
may remember they tried to tase them it
didn't work
he resisted uh and the attorney argues
and he's right that
if the officers had not shot and blake
had gotten into the car and driven away
and then something had happened to those
kids everybody would be blaming the
officers for not doing more to save them
and you know what else
we could pretty much guarantee it they
they would still be
they'd be accused of of racism even then
because then they'd be said
that it would be said that uh well they
didn't care enough about black children
so
because they're racist and so they let
this guy drive away and then something
horrible happened to kids
we all know that's what would happen so
the moment those officers arrived on the
scene
it was a lose-lose situation that didn't
matter what happened
lose lose but it looks like those
officers did
the right thing anyway uh not just so
it's not just that they shouldn't be
blamed or you know they didn't commit a
crime it's that they they acted
heroically
to save these innocent children
um and they should be given a lot of
credit for that number two
it was made official on saturday judge
amy coney barrett is trump's nominee for
the supreme court uh here he is
announcing the news
today it is my honor to nominate one of
our nation's most brilliant
and gifted legal minds to the supreme
court
she is a woman of unparalleled
achievement
towering intellect sterling credentials
and unyielding loyalty to the
constitution
judge amy coney barrett
of course the left as expected did its
thing jumping into action
uh finding ways to smear barrett's which
which is no easy task because
like trump said she's a respected and
brilliant judge she's a loving mother
impeccable credentials everyone likes
her good looking woman i mean the total
package so
what do you do how do you go about this
well fortunately if you're a lunatic
with the moral sensibilities of a
tapeworm
then it's not much of a challenge to
attack a woman even a woman like this
so here's here's a ibram ex candy
anti-racism expert supposedly the guy we
mentioned you may remember him last week
we mentioned him he got he got paid 20
grand
from a school district in virginia to do
a skype session where he talked about
why white people are bad
and he got paid 20 000. so this this
guy's got a you know nice little racket
going and
he uh chimed in to explain um
why in fact uh barrett adopt because
she's she's also an adoptive mother
she's she's a mother she's adopted
um uh i believe two children
and he's explaining why barrett adopting
black children
something that most people would see as
a mark in her favor character wise
um is not in fact it's the opposite she
he says some white colonizers
adopted black children they civilized
quote these
savage children in the superior ways of
white people
while using them as prompts in their
lifelong pictures of denial
while cutting the biological parents of
these children out of the picture of
humanity
um that's what he had to say about that
that's how he looks at
adoption most of us we look at and i
watch this
and it really did appear to be just a
wonderful
beautiful loving family sincerely you
know i know that
politicians and people that are in the
political scene which unfortunately now
supreme court justices are whether they
should be or not and they shouldn't be
but you know they all try to give the
impression of having wonderful loving
fully intact families and we know that
oftentimes that's certainly not the case
but in this case it really seems to be
it's just a loving
good wholesome family most of us see
that and that's how we feel about it but
people on the left they look at it and
they're
somehow they're disgusted by it
so this is what they're going to go with
they're really going to go with this
she's racist
because she has black children because
she has black children that's that's the
line of attack
you know like we talked about with trump
before you know it's like they have all
this this stuff on him
and and they haven't found that really
really found where the bodies are buried
so it makes us
think maybe there are no bodies well
even more so with amy coney barrett that
they're coming through her life looking
desperately for something
they'll take anything they can and what
they have to settle on
is attacking her because she adopted
kids
that tells you how how clean uh her
record must really be
impressive number three well the
election is basically over now folks i
think
now we haven't even had the debate yet
that's happening tomorrow but i think
this sort of seals the deal
for joe biden because the moment we've
been waiting for
has happened dwayne the rock johnson
has given his endorsement watch
happy sunday everybody we are
approximately five weeks away
from election day arguably the most
critical election
our country has seen in decades now that
said i'm going to be pushing this
political conversation
uh just a little bit more now you know
look i've got friends in all parties but
the one thing that we can always agree
on
is the conversation and the dialogue and
where that conversation lands
is always the most critical part now
this is something that i've certainly
not done in the past
so i'm gonna go big you guys know me if
i go
i go big so guys i had the opportunity
to sit down
with vice president joe biden and
senator kamala harris to talk about
a number of important issues that we're
facing as a country
i thought it was a great and extremely
productive conversation that we had
and as a registered independent for
years now with
census centrist excuse me ideologies
i do feel that vice president biden and
senator harris
are the best choice to lead our country
and i am endorsing them to become
president and vice president of our
united states
okay now just a few a few quick points
if i may first
look i'm in no position to body shame
the rock
uh he he could quite clearly snap me in
half with his pinkies
i'm sure but at the same time i do feel
like the muscular physique gets a little
bit absurd at a certain point
doesn't it just you you cross through a
threshold at a certain point
where it's like okay dude just relax
take it down a notch take it
i get the point just take it down a few
notches and i think the rock is
teetering close to that line
it's it's a little much is all i'm
saying that's it that's all i'm trying
to say
um second point probably more to the
point
why did joe biden sit down with the rock
i mean and when did this have biden has
been working two hours
two hour days for the last like 19 weeks
he calls it a lid on the day
at 9 30 a.m most mornings and yet he had
time to meet with dwayne the rock
johnson
is that why he was calling a lid in
order to have extensive
meetings with the rock i'm imagining
five or six hour long meetings every day
for weeks on end
hashing out domestic policy foreign
policy everything with the rock that's
what i'm imagining
but as usual my imagination has no
connection to reality um
actually because we have the
conversation here's what the
conversation between the rock and joe
biden
really sounded like you guys are are
both obviously experienced to lead
you've done great things joe you've had
such an incredible career
you've led in my opinion with great
compassion and
in heart and drive
but also soul and you and i talked about
that in the past and how important soul
is
and uh come live i'm going to embarrass
you just for a little bit because i'm
going to talk a little bit about your
uh your amazing experience and you have
been an
attorney a district attorney a state
attorney
a u.s senator smart tough i've seen you
in those hearings
and um in my opinion you are certified
badass
wow he grilled them didn't he he really
he he held their feet to the fire
and but he was also definitely i hope
you noticed that he was definitely
reading
all of that information about camilla
harris
he was he didn't know anything about her
he was saying camilla i know so much
about you
um i've always been a huge supporter for
your whole career in the um
senate yeah big fan of camilla harris
there i mean
but in fairness to him and this is why i
give him credit i think he has a pretty
good actor uh
to to pretend that you're a big fan of
camilla harris
that's no easy task so that's probably
his greatest acting moment
i think was right there number four in
more celebrity news singer john legend
says that he and his wife chrissy teigen
might be kind
might be are thinking of of maybe
leaving the united states if donald
trump is reelected
um now as many have pointed out this
seems like a bit of an idle threat
considering they apparently just bought
a 17 million
mansion in in beverly hills not the kind
of thing you do
if you're planning on fleeing a country
because it's become a fascist wasteland
in fact not the kind of thing you could
do probably if it was a fascist
wasteland
but besides that of course you just have
to reflect on the
psychotic narcissism of these
celebrities
that they think it's some sort of
effective form of blackmail to threaten
to leave the country
as if we're all gonna fall to the ground
grabbing at their feet like no don't
leave us please
we can't we can't go on without you don
john legend
i don't think anyone's gonna have that
reaction even if you're a fan of john
legend what do you care where he lives
what difference does it make it's a
little similar on a smaller scale it
reminds me of
the thing that people do to me online
all the time they probably it's a
comment they probably do to youtube
but on social media i get this kind of
thing all the time on a smaller scale
where where someone will threaten to
unfollow me or un
unfriend me because i express an opinion
they don't like
and my favorite is when they when they
say something like you know i'm really
thinking of unfollowing you now matt
i'm thinking of it this this opinion
that's got me thinking i might unfollow
and again it's as if i'm supposed to
break down in tears and plead with them
and say no
i'll change i promise don't leave me
it'll be different this time i promise
um we can go to counseling together no
just doesn't
doesn't work the threat doesn't work
nobody cares that much
whoever you are whether you're john
legend you're just a normal a random
person on the internet no one cares that
much what you do or what you think so
don't don't try to hold it as a a
bargaining chip number five finally this
is um interesting from the daily star
always a reputable publication uh it
says real life inception
as scientists figure out how to plant
ideas in dreams
and then it goes on it may sound like a
plot of inception but scientists have
figured out how to plant ideas into
other people's dreams researchers at mit
media labs fluid interfaces
have been testing a new technique called
targeted dream incubation
which allows them to insert topics into
someone's dream
uh let's see how do they do this the
study involved 25 participants taking
daytime naps before going to bed they
would record audio prompts in an app
such as remember to think of a tree and
remember to observe your thoughts
okay then they just oh okay well that's
a bummer
i thought this would be some kind of
fancy technological thing like hacking
into someone's brain you know
something from the matrix but no they
just they just remind themselves before
going to bed hey
i should think of a tree and then they
wake up and say yo i had a dream about a
tree
not i don't know that's why is this a
new revelation
and why is it being studied at all
and and speaking of dreams being being
on a research team where my whole
job is to listen to dream stories from
other people
that's my nightmare that's my personal
nightmare
because there is nothing worse than
listening to someone drone on about
their stupid dream
that they think is so profound and they
tell you about it but really it's just
boring
they tell you they say oh man i had a
dream last night where i was walking
down the road
and then uh the road turned into a snake
pit
and uh then the snakes turned into candy
canes
and i and i and i started to fly and
next thing you know ronald reagan was
there and
no stop first of all you're embellishing
half of this and i can tell
second i don't care um dreams are only
interesting to the dreamer
to everyone else a dream is just bad
storytelling
rule of thumb we should take that with
us all of us
dreams are cancelled well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt walsh
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content